[Music]
at least I can hear that yeah yeah loud
and clear
I've been fishing in some remote places
but never in front of an audience of
hippos I'm cause you're looking over
because those things Josh lonely yes how
that thing's getting closer yes I can
see it we are safe for now are you sure
yes yes I'll tell you when to run lonely
Oh three times heavier than you I don't
move that quickly yeah second faster
than you trust me I'm not leaving here
till I catch a decent fish yes yes come
on bass I'd like to catch fish come on
oh I think I've got one yeah yeah yeah
no no I have yes you missed it no no
he's on spill on Easter yes yes pull it
back slowly slowly now that is a good
one for the team for the chief yeah now
lonely may have caught the most fish but
let's be honest I caught the biggest I
want to save my fish for the chief so
I'm taking one of lonely's back to Zona
she might assume that I caught it but if
you don't say anything I won't either
I'd like you to scale and gut that guy
for me please gallon gutter the point
here for the week is to hone your Zulu
warrior skills price Brian is
quintessential we're keeping it very
plain very simple just a little bit of
seasoning the ingredients speak for
themselves generally which is you know
in line with with tradition in terms of
our flavor profile as to do people
gotcha
so here I'm making something called a
Shack teeny it's a combination of onions
and tomatoes chopped up which I've got
here and I've been mentioning to you how
you know the Zulu palette is very
simplistic but pays it in is the biggest
population of Indian people outside of
India we do add a touch of chili
everyone in rice is that sort of culture
has infiltrated throughout the region so
no
oil no oil no no oil remember this is
Zulu warrior cookie sure it was no such
thing as olive oil available etc so you
just wind straight straight on to the
fire so wherever you see the coals at
their whitest yeah you'll know that
they're the right temperature there you
go good sizzle Wow
what's becoming very obvious is this
it's very simple it's tribal cooking in
a way that it's a huge emphasis on the
fish and the meat what's the big no nose
for the chief do the people in general
do not like their meat ring I know
Gordon so you're gonna want to give a
symptom medium range perhaps is just
fine
suggest he takes it medium rare I've
never heard anyone suggest anything to
the chief before but you could be the
first Gordon beautiful beautiful fresh
piece of fish and then I'm gonna pop the
shotty knee on top of the flesh amazing
how simple it is and you think of the
face warrior in terms of what he what he
stands for how important he is and look
how simple that is that's it simple
delicious good fishing that's delicious
mmm so good so good that's so simple so
simple all the ingredients speak for
themselves I will see you I'll see you
into the week at the end of the week any
tips mostly listen and learn and always
remember the chief is a hard man to
please gotcha good luck thank you
sounds like I'll need it
[Music]
want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips